disco delivers affordable science-backed
skin care treatments to your home the
Disco Starter Set helps guys fight oily
skin and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated I've had great results with it
you'll get 30 percent off at
letsdisco.com Pacman the link is down
below
so we had some major Media news
yesterday many of you emailing me about
it tweeting to me about it sending me
very very respectful to uh all sorts of
messages about it
um the story is Chris Wallace leaving
Fox News and joining CNN plus CNN plus
being a new streaming service from CNN
and this is a really big deal in the
political media space because Chris
Wallace as many of you know was one of
what we would call the loan occasional
voices of reason on Fox News which was
basically a sea of propaganda and I've
had a number of different thoughts about
Chris Wallace's presence on Fox in the
past which there's no better time to
talk about than now but let's first take
a look at Chris Wallace making the
announcement yesterday on Fox News
Sunday after 18 years this is my final
Fox News Sunday it is the last time and
I say this with real sadness we will
meet like this
18 years ago the boss was here at Fox
promised me they would never interfere
with a guest I booked or a question I
asked and they kept that promise I have
been free to report to the best of my
ability to cover the stories I think are
important to hold our country's leaders
to account
it's been a great ride we've covered
five presidential elections interviewed
every president since George H.W bush
traveled the world sitting down with
France's Emmanuel macron and Russia's
Vladimir Putin
and I've gotten to spend Sunday mornings
with you
it may sound corny but I feel we built a
community here there's a lot you can do
on Sunday mornings the fact you've
chosen to spend this hour with us is
something I cherish
but after 18 years I have decided to
leave Fox I want to try something new to
go beyond politics to all the things I'm
interested in I'm ready for a new
adventure and I hope you'll check it out
and so for the last time dear friends
okay so he's leaving he said he has new
projects and then within two hours CNN
announced he's going to be joining as an
anchor of their new streaming service
CNN plus which doesn't exist yet it's
expected to debut early next year so is
this good or is this bad and for who or
whom depending on your preference
um on the one hand it's been clear for a
long time
that Chris Wallace's days at Fox were
probably numbered if he was going to
keep asking just real questions of
Republicans when Republicans would be on
and we had all of these different
examples of I don't even remember what
Senator it was who was talking about
debt and Chris Wallace pointed out well
a lot of that debt accrued under Trump
not under Joe Biden and you know this
looks like in other countries we would
call it basic journalism it was rare on
Fox and because Chris Wallace was doing
it and he was doing it with the
Republicans as well as Democrats it was
rare it stood out and there was some
sense that at some point he might be
gone now on the one hand you could say
his mere presence on Fox was a net
positive
because there were some viewers who were
fully accepting all the propaganda
and even if they didn't care that this
is what Chris Wallace was doing they
would be exposed to it for a moment and
maybe he would change some minds and get
some of these mindless Fox viewers to
think hey here's another perspective the
Counterpoint to that is that Chris
Wallace did provide Fox News cover in a
major way to be able to say we're fair
and balanced we have news and we have
opinion that's one they've been hiding
behind for a very long time it's like
yes you have news and opinion it's
blurred and even the news sounds like
opinion and we have plenty of people
holding Republicans accountable like
Chris Wallace they used to have Shep
Smith although Shep Smith left and in
that sense it provided cover for Fox
News to be marginally more plausible as
an actual news channel of sorts with
actual journalism being done and so with
Chris Wallace leaving does it prevent
Fox from now having that cover my bottom
line on this is as follows I think it's
a it you've got two sides of the scale
and they're they're really both doing
work it's close right on the one hand
his presence is good as an alternative
to the propaganda on the other hand his
presence allows Fox to run interference
my expectation
is that now Chris Wallace will be
replaced with a total partisan hack uh
people on on Twitter were talking about
Dana Perino Dana Perino who's a Fox
anchor now was George W Bush's press
secretary right I mean give me a break
guys so he'll probably replace be
replaced with someone much worse I think
that by a small margin small margin
Wallace on Fox was a net positive he did
ask real questions and maybe convince
some people he did allow Fox to say we
have a variety and we have journalism
and we have Chris Wallace I think the
the benefit of having him there
slightly slightly outweighed the very
pernicious reality that he was running
interference for what was otherwise a
complete and total propaganda uh media
outlet and in particular if he now gets
replaced with Tucker or a Hannity
wannabe not not literally Tucker but a
Tucker or Hanabi uh Tucker or Hannity
wannabe
um I think we are worse off and so the
criticism that he ran interference for a
horrible propaganda network is 100
accurate and I would say by like five
percent him being there was a net
benefit do you disagree with me I want
to hear from you for a long time the
American right wing has been using their
narrow and myopic cartoonish outdated
view of masculinity and femininity to
attack anybody they can on the left of
course uh you might remember back in the
2004 presidential election a big
narrative a big movement was feminized
John Kerry John Kerry was the Democratic
Presidential nominee in 2004 running
against George W bush who was the
Republican running for reelection and
the story was Bush is masculine he
clears brush with a chainsaw in Texas he
throws a baseball well and on the other
hand the storyline from these right
Wingers was John Kerry is feminine
because he windsurfed spoke French
imagine speaking another language now is
feminine and once sort of fumble the
football that was thrown to him and of
course this in and of itself didn't
really fit the facts the facts were her
Carrie was the military veteran who
served in combat in Vietnam
Bush was able to be barely involved in
the military thanks to family
connections by their own standards Kerry
should have been seen as the masculine
one but it didn't matter the tactic is
you feminize the person in the
Democratic party but okay that was 2004.
we hadn't really seen this tactic during
covid except for the occasional wearing
a mask is gay type of stuff that we've
previously covered on the show they are
now really upping the ante on that
talking point Fox News propagandist
Tucker Carlson during an interview with
British right-winger Nigel farage
said that getting coveted not getting
the vaccine getting covered you get sick
with covid it feminizes you makes you
more like a woman let's take a look at
the clip Bishop quality yes yes we're
gonna go and climb that Hill
and here's why we want to do it and we
invite you the public to come with us on
that Journey amen that is leadership and
Boris just with the best will in the
world doesn't have that and
we've seen more u-turns in policy from
the Johnson government than I've seen in
any government in my lifetime and uh in
a very embarrassing way some of it's
been shocking so somebody who knows him
told me and I I should be initially
getting your take on this that getting
covid emasculated him it changed him we
it feminized him it weakened him as a
man do you think that's well I think he
was very seriously ill for sure he was I
think I mean one of the things we have
learned from covid is people who are 50
60 70 80 pounds overweight tend to have
fed very badly sure now we don't talk
about it but the virus itself this is
true does tend to take away the life
force in some people I know this I mean
it does feminize people no one ever says
that but it's true I look I think the
virus did affect him but I think let's
be honest about it it's it's the new
wife isn't it I mean it's you know
Carrie Johnson or as she's now called
Carrie Antoinette the historians like
now of course if this is true if getting
sick from covid is feminine all those
right-wing radio hosts who denounced the
vaccine didn't get vaccinated ultimately
got coveted and died that's very very
feminine by this metric that Tucker
Carlson is laying out for us I actually
got hit with this firsthand I don't know
how many of you remember a few years ago
I fainted on an airplane sort of I've
fainted a few times in my life to sort
of a combination of dehydration
elevation coffee alcohol you know bad
combination of stuff and when I told the
story
some people commented on YouTube what a
[ __ ] and others said it was a medical
event you know like it's not uh it's not
feminine or masculine it's just a
medical reality and that's essentially
the same thing that Tucker is doing here
now there's one other funny thing about
this these right Wingers don't apply
this standard to their own none of them
said
feminized Herman Cain what a woman when
he got coveted and died he was a friend
of trump he was a Republican a Jordan
Peterson has been in and out of all
sorts of treatments for what year two
years now I guess he's out now but he
was in for close to a couple years
hospitals in Eastern Europe Etc they
never said how feminine of Jordan
Peterson and in fact he still had his
fans in acolytes hanging on his every
word so as usual it's a silly idea it's
a dumb idea disease as feminine is being
sick as feminine but they also only
apply it when it's convenient to their
narrative I actually do think
maybe some of you would disagree major
progress has been made on on some of
this stuff and fortunately more of the
population in the U.S don't see this
bizarre narrow definition of masculinity
as relevant you know men hug more now in
U.S culture than before it's been no big
deal in most cultures for a long time in
the US there was more of it that's
that's gay man
um but that it's diminished to some
degree so I I actually think on this
particular issue
um some progress has been made but it
still persists in many many places and
as usual it's the hypocritical
application of these standards that's
particularly nonsensical so no real
surprise I I genuinely don't think
Tucker believes any of this stuff and
you and I meaning people in the audience
have called in before to talk about is
Tucker for real is he pretending the
anti-vax stuff he's certainly vaccinated
right I'm sure all his family was
vaccinated the first day they became
eligible I don't know but my instinct is
I think Tucker's a terrible person
because he's willing to do this stuff
but I'm leaning towards it's all Bs I
don't really think he believes more than
half of these nonsense talking points
that he comes up with I think it's for
the show I think it's performative I
think it's for ratings and that's
nothing I would ever do you all know if
I tell you something on this show it's
actually what I believe let me know what
you think you can find me on Twitter at
DPAC women is Tucker for real with these
talking points or are they just
performative also remember that tomorrow
is the last and final David Pacman show
viewer Town Hall of the year
6 p.m Eastern 3 P.M Pacific Tuesday
December 14th it'll be streaming live on
the Pac-Man Live YouTube channel and if
you want to participate you can get
connected on the David packman show
Discord at davidpackman.com Discord
one of our sponsors is Disco there are
so many different types of bogus skin
care products for men out there what you
really want to go with is just something
affordable effective and created by
dermatologists that's why we have disco
which delivers the science-backed
over-the-counter skin treatments that
dermatologists recommend to their
patients every day the Disco Starter Set
is a simple way to take care of your
skin in three quick steps the face
cleanser stick fights oily skin the
exfoliating face scrub prevents razor
burn and the face moisturizer keeps your
skin hydrated disco can also help with
ingrown hairs dry skin acne and other
things you just need 60 seconds a day
I've been using it for a while now I'm
seeing a noticeable difference maybe you
can even tell check out disco try out
the products for yourself you will like
the results and you'll get 30 off when
you go go to
let'sdisco.com Pacman or just enter the
code Pacman the link is down below so I
very gladly spent a bunch of time this
weekend setting up orders for free David
packman show t-shirts we made this offer
last week I said folks sirs ma'ams uh
children everybody the last few months
we've seen a little bit of a decline in
David Pacman show website membership
it's been a tough final few months of
the year we are offering free t-shirts
to everybody who signs up for a new
membership at the full yearly rate of
sixty dollars a bunch of the emails I
got were people who just didn't
understand they said uh okay I just got
a monthly membership where's my t-shirt
or
just people that were confused and but
that's okay that's par for the course in
this business many of you did go and
actually get full price yearly
memberships and ask me for the t-shirts
and we are pumping them out and let's
extend the offer for this week as well
you sign up at joinpakman.com at the
full yearly price of sixty dollars
full yearly price of sixty dollars
you're a new member email info
davidpackman.com and we'll get that free
t-shirt right out to you at this point
it isn't clear that anything would
actually shock us about the Trump riots
but we have now learned something that
is sort of shocking about the attempt to
steal the election from Joe Biden by
Donald Trump
there was a PowerPoint
they put it in writing this was
happening at the highest levels of the
Trump Administration the plan was
extensive the plan was specific and
detailed and they actually implemented
certain elements of the plan of course
not succeeding and actually stealing the
election if it weren't totally
predictable it would be surprising but
it does come as a shock in terms of the
attack on Democracy that this
represented and four years ago we
certainly would not have imagined that
they would go this far we knew there was
a memo from a lawyer outlining
mechanisms that could be attempted to
try to steal the election from Joe Biden
but this became a PowerPoint
presentation with suggestions such as
declare a state of emergency
put in place a different slate of
electors and all of this is relevant
because for so long they denied the
rumors that they were thinking of
declaring a state of emergency that it
was ever a discussion so what this all
is about is a PowerPoint presentation
obtained by the house committee
investigating the Trump riots the
PowerPoint is called election fraud
foreign interference and options for
January 6th and these are options for
trying to prevent Joe Biden
from being certified as the winner which
of course he was the PowerPoint was
turned over to the investigative
committee by former Trump Chief of Staff
Mark Meadows it is real and it is
spectacular here are some slides from it
and of course all the rumors were true
they denied it all the things we
believed they were planning they were
indeed planning first slide called
options for January 6th lists VP Pence
seats Republican electors over the
objections of Dems in states where fraud
occurred
we knew they were planning this just
Mike Pence says because there is fraud
in Arizona
instead of seeding the Democratic
electors we have an alternate slate of
Republican electors insane insane second
option VP Pence rejects electors from
states where fraud occurred causing the
election to be decided by the remaining
electoral vote so the idea there is if
you just take off the table some of the
electors instead of needing 270 now
maybe you only need 230 or 210 or
whatever the idea is you take enough
States off the table that Trump's actual
electors that he did win are more than
50 that was the second option third
option VP Pence delays decision to allow
for vetting and accounting of legal
paper ballots the idea being well they
would say a ton of these are not legal
and throw them out that was a slide for
the coup
like a book report but for a coup
another slide called recommendations
actually says on it declare a National
Security emergency
claim foreign interference and control
of voting systems remember they denied
denied denied that there was even a
vulnerability to foreign actors back in
2016. now all of a sudden they want to
use it here it was let's use it
ourselves to steal the election and then
third recommendation declare electronic
voting in all states invalid they denied
they were thinking about this stuff and
it is on the PowerPoint
um in another slide called summary of
domestic voter fraud they list all of
the things that they eventually did Trot
out now this stuff they tried okay
double voters people voted twice dead
voters that one we spent a lot of time
debunking non-citizen voters they can't
even register to vote fake ballots like
just a ballot you make at home I guess
they list eight states they are exactly
the states that they talked about
Michigan Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Minnesota Georgia Nevada
Arizona New Mexico
they did all of it this was the game
plan they tried it fortunately they
didn't get away with it now they didn't
ultimately try declaring the National
Security emergency or maybe Trump did
and someone stopped him when we don't
know yet
we just have to wait so there's a few
takeaways here
confirmed for the tenth time they were
lying all along about what they were
planning
what they were thinking of what they
would be willing to do it was lie after
lie after lie confirmation not
surprising second we were right about
this being very serious and probably
something they're going to try again now
we all had a good old time laughing at
the wacky stuff right Rudy giuliani's
face melting the hair dye Sydney Powell
visibly perplexed by her own arguments
you know oh okay I get it Trump the big
baby still won't admit he lost all of it
but this is not a game and when I said
last week in my commentary based on a
article that we talked about
um the next coup is already being
planned the first attempt was practice
for the next one this is very serious
this is not the last we've heard from
this idea now third and last
when does the Department of Justice get
involved Merrick Garland has been very
hesitant I can understand the reasons
why he might feel that it would not
maybe be good to get involved in this
but how does the doj justify not getting
involved when every single fact is so
utterly insane and dangerous that's the
question that remains and we can't put
our guard down even for a second
I have to play a video for you today
that is out of this world cringe this is
giga cringe that's what the kids call it
and it really shows us how sort of
backwards like what counts as humor
is completely backwards in American
right-wing culture right now but it also
shows as hypocrisy and that's an
important part of this as well so let me
set it up for you there is a comedian
some say an comedian and I'm completely
an historian I'm behind and comedian it
cannot be comedian Jim Brewer
he has become sort of a darling of the
right wing over uh his commentary about
the pandemic because he was on Tucker
Carlson speaking out against vaccine
mandates he has moved shows around to
try to circumvent vaccination
requirements we had a clip of him making
a total fool out of himself on Tucker
Carlson's show about a month ago I have
never found this guy funny I used to
hear him on the Howard Stern Show a
decade ago two decades ago and I always
said this guy's not funny I don't know
why he's on I didn't know anything about
his politics he has become even less
funny and the material I'm about to play
for you I watch this it gave me chills I
had chicken skin from watching this
cringe so here's a clip of Jim Brewer
and this counts as comedy for the
American right wing folks and he's sort
of doing a bird impression now hold on
that could be funny maybe I don't know
and the bird impression is to mock
people who pay attention to scientists
Specialists and doctors rather than I
guess right-wing media figures and
quacks and he does the bird impression
while saying things like fauci science
and for me the notable part of this is
there have been unfunny comedians for a
long time that's not new the most
notable part is that they pan to people
in the audience this is at one of these
reawaken America events
um and people are just losing their
minds laughing pointing laughing they're
in hysterics do these people not get out
of their house and so for me that says
way more about the people who like this
stuff Brewer hasn't been funny for
decades but the audience acting like
this is the Vanguard of Comedy is
amazing so take a look at the video you
know what a cockatoo is
cockatoo
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and that that's what everyone's become
little cockatoo staring at the screen
facts and figures facts and figure Dr
fauci Dr faucy
ah trust the science trust the science
at Specialists specialist numbers going
up numbers going up one mess two Max
fascinated double
yeah so the and I apologize for showing
that to you the crowd just has never
seen anything this funny this is again
it's the reawaken America Tour it's a
right-wing tour it's like a circus it
goes around the country and it's a
combination of anti-vax
covid denial
I guess Christianity and conspiracy
theories that's what it is and so
there's a bunch of stuff here the
hysterical crowd pointing and laughing
like it's just so it it's we've never
seen anything this funny do these people
literally not leave their houses like
are you just watching paint dry all day
that this is what makes you laugh it's
very very strange or are you just so
desperate for something pretending to be
comedy that makes fun of the left to be
funny that you are willing to laugh at
anything and then here's the hypocrisy
and I want to make sure everybody
understands this
Jim Brewer laughed at science
Specialists numbers going up following
data
when Jim Brewer's wife was sick with
cancer he went on the radio and he was
asked about it I don't remember if it
was Opie and Anthony or one of those
shows
and he said
we are going to the best specialist I
mean he he used the word in this clip he
laughs at listening to Specialists
because it's covet
when his wife was sick he went to
Specialists he said we're going to we're
finding the best Specialists we're
looking at the research and the
double-blind placebo-controlled trials
which we are now dismissing when it
comes to covid we are looking at
clinical trials We are following the
science when it came down to his wife he
wasn't doing this act he was going to
the exact professionals and trusting the
exact system that he now ridicules you
can find that segment if you look for it
oh I Sirius XM is very litigious with uh
copyright but you can find that segment
so as usual
disgusting value going out there and
saying specialist
but he doesn't even really appear
to adhere to those very values when the
rubber meets the road gross and by the
way the rights still can't do comedy
nothing has changed there folks we'll
have this clip up on our Instagram uh
make sure you're following us there at
davidpackman show we'll take a quick
break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
okay so over the weekend there was a Fox
News Channel interview the interviewer
was Laura Ingram the interview e was the
former president Donald Trump this is a
very relevant interview for the next two
election Cycles now that it's clear they
would try the coup again if they could
now that it's clear Donald Trump is
planning to be involved in 2022 and
quite plausibly in 2024 now that we know
that the coup had a PowerPoint I mean
all of the stuff
uh this must be taken really really
seriously so we're going to go through a
number of different lies told by Trump
but we're going to really build to the
commentary about what may be coming in
the future for the United States so
first just to reintroduce us to the
uncontrollable lying Donald Trump again
makes very deceptive and untrue claims
about gas prices now why the gas price
issue is even an issue remember there's
a lot of people who play the political
football of blaming or praising
presidents for high or low gas prices
depending on what is convenient based on
your partisan affiliation I don't play
that game presidents have almost nothing
to do with gas prices but Trump plays
the game he says when he left office gas
was at a dollar 87 and now it's at 777
in California if those numbers sound
weird they should and let's look at the
clip first you look at gas prices
gasoline was at one dollar and 87 cents
a gallon and now in California it's over
seven dollars seven seventy seven to be
exact and it's going to be catching up
with a lot of other parts of the country
so okay so it's all either a lie or
deceptive when Trump left office gas was
a dollar 87 he says that's not true
when Trump left office gas was 242. so
is it higher today yes but was it a
dollar eighty seven no when Trump left
office it was 30 percent higher at 242.
Trump says gas is now 777 in California
and what's dishonest about that well
even if it were true that gas prices are
777 in California comparing California
to the National number doesn't make
sense the official national gas price is
now 349. so you don't compare 187 or the
real number 242 a year ago or when you
left office to a specific gas station in
California that doesn't make sense you
compare it to the official number in the
U.S and that is now 349. it's 349
instead of 242. is gas more now than
when Trump left yes it is dramatically
uh uh it's a dramatically smaller Gap
than what Trump claimed and remember
presidents don't control gas prices now
lastly even the California number is
Hawaii California gas right now uh the
national the theory the official state
number is 460. not 777. is there some
gas station in California
where super premium maybe was 777 maybe
I don't know but that's not how you look
at numbers so it's all lies and he keeps
telling them Trump then says and this is
totally unintelligible he's like his
brain is glitching it's like mayonnaise
um or Vegenaise Trump claims Democrats
are going to try to use the debt ceiling
for the Supreme Court and other stuff I
don't even know what he's saying take a
listen you absolutely kill that now
they're going to use it for the Supreme
Court and even worse than that they're
going to use it for the so-called voting
rights which is a disaster for our
country and certainly it's a disaster
for the Republican Party
yeah I don't think that's going to pass
but um Arizona just off the wall
Off the Wall no idea what mechanisms he
is even referring to Trump was then
asked about invoking or attempting to
invoke executive privilege even though
he's no longer president over documents
related to the January 6th Trump riots
and he again says there was no
Insurrection on January 6th the
Insurrection was Election Day November
of 2020. this is his new talking point
and I'll explain it in a moment and hear
about the executive privilege and
Biden's decision to release those
documents your reaction tonight
well we're gonna have to see what
happens uh if you look at the protest it
was a protest the Insurrection took
place on November 3rd which was election
day this was a protest that a lot of
innocent people are being hurt a lot of
innocent people are being injured uh I
would say the panel of Judges that we're
talking about didn't exactly like Trump
uh and if you look at the appointments
you can figure that one out for yourself
but this was a absolute protest and
people are being treated very very
unfairly their rights are being taken
away from them and the other side is not
you take a look at what's going on with
BLM and antifa what they did in Portland
and Minneapolis and Seattle and nothing
happens but what happened by the way
people were killed nobody was killed
here other than Ashley Babbitt who was
shot violently by a man that should not
have ever been allowed to pull that
trigger is saying okay so so the the
talk the story is Trump says
the what happened on January 6th was not
a coup it was not an Insurrection and my
supporters weren't violent
the it was BLM and antifa if anyone was
violent but otherwise it was a peaceful
protest the real Insurrection was when
they stole it from me him
in November of 2020 and he also
continues to insist that all of these
hundreds of defendants the rioters were
um actually innocent and now are being
treated poorly it's wild I mean these
and now is where it starts to get
dangerous because people believe this
stuff and they're gonna try it again in
2024 with Trump or with someone else
Trump then attacked attacks the makeup
of the January 6th committee and says
they aren't real Republicans it's only
kinzinger and Cheney but why is that
well let's look at the clip and then
I'll explain we have Liz Liz Cheney and
kinzinger two people that should not be
on the committee we don't have
Republicans on the I call it the
unselect committee of democrat partisans
it's ridiculous what's going on with it
and he has done a terrible job you have
the I call it the infrastructure bill
because it's not infrastructure so Trump
says they don't have real Republicans
they only have people like Adam
kinzinger and Liz Cheney well that's
because other Republicans abandoned the
initial plan for the committee and said
we're not going to participate which
made Nancy Pelosi have to go out and
find Republicans willing to be on it
does it mean we wouldn't prefer a
different makeup of the community no of
course not but come on it's another
deceptive claim so here's what's very
clearly going on Trump is dramatically
accelerating the pace of his media
interviews over the last two weeks why
the 2022 midterms are about to start
he's ramping up for 2022. he wants to be
the king maker he wants people donating
to him so that through his pack he can
support candidates he is definitely
going to be involved in campaigns in
2022 and then
this is all part of the build up to try
again
with any means necessary any means they
can get away with in 2024 there is no
doubt now whether the candidate will be
Trump that's a different question we
don't know the answer to that yet over
the last 10 days more and more people
saying it's going to be Trump uh I think
his health may be the biggest limiting
factor we just don't know yet but this
is building he's doing interviews more
and more frequently to sell the book
sure but also because we are about to
get very much in with uh what might be
some of the most anticipated I mean it
sounds cliche but in a way what is going
to happen we all Democrats uh lose
everything other than the White House in
November of 22 or not and Trump wants to
be very much involved okay in the
meantime this you really have to see
this weekend in Florida was the opening
night of the much promoted and hyped
tour of disgraced former Fox News
superhero Bill O'Reilly really
interviewing disgraced former president
Donald Trump it was half empty I mean it
was a genuine embarrassment in this
picture from the opening night in
Sunrise Florida you can see that the
floor seats are about 40 percent empty
then they announced before the show
started if you have cheap seats in the
upper decks we're going to close the
upper decks come on down and sit in the
lower level for free you don't even have
to pay anything extra
sales were so terrible that tickets were
available right up until the show
started for three dollars per ticket in
many sections day two not much vet
better we have a video of the event
right before it started and as you can
see uh very very light turnout on the
way out some hilarious interviews with
people
here's an interview with a woman who
went to the event and she said you know
I love Trump as much as anybody
but he kind of goes off on tangents and
repeats things that we already know
well I thought Bill did an excellent job
of trying to steer the questions that he
had prepared to more of an historical
nature because it's very difficult I
love president Trump but he can go a bit
off on tangents and perhaps repeat some
of the things that we all know but Bill
tried to make it a little different and
make it more of a history tour
um imagine trying to ask Trump
historical questions he knows nothing
about history he barely even understand
like he's been tricked into thinking
certain countries that don't exist our
countries remember when he mispronounced
country countries that don't exist uh
African countries Etc
um here's another interview with a guy
leaving the show uh this I don't know if
this was uh the Sunday show or the night
before
um he says the media covered up although
the good things Trump did so it was good
to hear it from Trump directly you can
imagine what that sounded like and uh he
also said it was great that Bill
O'Reilly was the interviewer because
Bill O'Reilly is a Centrist who doesn't
take sides are you familiar with what
Bill O'Reilly dude take a look since
you're gonna have a truly Fair time in
office you know we heard more of the
negative stuff on media you know we
never heard the good stuff he was doing
and so it's really good to hear from a a
person like Bill O'Reilly who was very
middle of the road we didn't like pick
size is this guy really unaware I mean
he looks young maybe he really doesn't
know that Bill O'Reilly was for a Time
the most prominent conservative on Fox
News he ultimately lost his show sexual
harassment allegations all sorts of
horrible stuff but for like 20 years or
18 years he was the top conservative
voice of Fox News and was considered up
there with Rush Limbaugh doesn't take
sides I mean it's just a fantasy world
so what can we read into the lack of
turnout I would read very little into it
quite frankly I think the reason that a
lot of people didn't go to this show is
number one early on even cheap seats
were selling for a hundred bucks a lot
of people just don't have that kind of
money
to go sit in the nosebleeds and listen
to Trump talk to Bill O'Reilly so I
think the early pricing was a factor two
you can love Trump
and hate Democrats and plan to vote for
Trump
and just be tired of hearing the same
nonsense from them over and over again
so the very same people who might just
get bored at his rallies we cover
Trump's rallies when he did them and
even the people on the stage were bored
you would have a guy checking his phone
tapping his wife clearly saying can we
go some people would fall asleep others
would just leave you can be bored by
that they're still voting for Trump at
the end of the day so I don't think the
lack of turnout is a sign that we can
safely look away from the threat of what
might happen in 22 and 24 and say we
don't have to worry about these
trumpians I think we do but it's also
really boring to listen to Trump repeat
the same thing hour after hour after
hour I think that's as far as I would go
in reading into this
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so I have
some genuinely great news for you today
you know most of the stories uh that we
have when you do news and politics are
unfortunately stories of people doing
things we don't want bad things happen
things we have to resist but here's a
good story something that we should
welcome uh and I'm doing the story
knowing it's not going to get a lot of
clicks not that many people care about
it because I care about it I think that
this is good the Latino civil rights
organization the league of United United
Latin American citizens has officially
dropped latinx as a gender-neutral term
for referring to Latino Or Hispanic
individuals of which I am one uh and the
organization's president Domingo Garcia
sent out an email last week saying we
are stopping the use of latinx in all
communication it's very unliked by most
Latinos and of course that that's a
factor that's something that certainly
should be considered now there are a ton
of organizations still using it but one
organization saying we're not going to
use it anymore is a good thing and I've
been against this term for a while when
people have asked about it I've
mentioned it anecdotally but I've not
really done a segment about it as many
of you know
um I'm from Argentina grew up speaking
Spanish my mom teaches Spanish
Literature and language at the college
level has for decades with my family
being from Argentina and politically
involved as you can imagine this idea of
latinx particularly in the the United
States is something that I've been
involved in you know a dozen hours or
more of discussion about over the years
I have been opposed to this term for a
number of reasons now first of all
Spanish is different than English and it
really makes no grammatical sense now I
know many but wait David hold on a
second sir some people say referring to
a trans person as they make snow
grammatical sense if it's the right
thing to do then it's the right thing to
do okay first of all they singular
actually makes plenty of sense if you
look at the history of the English
language people actually use it even
today all the time without even
realizing they're using they to refer to
one person latinx is a completely
different category but it's not wrong
that one could argue even if it makes no
grammatical sense we might say for
reasons of justice and equity
let's make it part of the language if
you want okay we go to the next issue
the problem with latinx is that it did
not stem from a desire from within the
global Latino Community to change
language to be more gender inclusive or
gender neutral latinx was pushed
primarily by non-latino people the
origins aren't a hundred percent clear
it might have been academic in origin it
might have come from the feminist
Community there were a number of
professors in the U.S who at one point
argued for changing the term Chicano to
chican X rather than Chicano Chicana
chican X and at the same time there
might have been some people said let's
do the same thing with latinx but the
point is it was mostly embraced by
non-latino people and in survey after
survey almost no Latino folks actually
use the term or preferred it and many
didn't
know what it was I once hosted an awards
show
for a Latino organization and on the
scripts they sent me for introducing
different Awards it said latinx and I
said listen guys I don't speak that way
my audience knows I don't speak that way
it's going to be very obviously not
genuine if all of a sudden I'm saying
latinx and they said okay don't use it
and the ease with which they just said
don't use it signaled to me this may be
going out at some point soon so the
point here isn't language can't change
over time of course it can we don't use
the r word as an insult I mean listen
there are people that do but it's oh I
cringe when I hear someone use the r
word as an insult we don't call people
or I don't the f word as an insult uh at
least many of us don't we don't say or I
don't that's gay when I want to say
something is bad
and that has sort of removed itself from
the culture because the culture is what
changed not because it was suddenly said
the word is done there of course have
been attempts to say in a school setting
or whatever we don't use this word or we
don't use that word or here's the word
that you use but that's fundamentally my
real issue with latinx this was not a
cultural movement from within whose
natural conclusion was let's use the
term Latin X rather than Latino or
Latina it was from above let's just
change the language and then we'll fix
the other stuff that comes with it and
of course we can deal with issues of
gender inequality gender inequality
within the Latino Community Etc without
having to come in and say this is now
the word that is being used so I like
that it was dropped in this case I think
it's a good thing I hope it goes away
completely I'm going to continue not
using the word while I fight and argue
for
all of the very things that the words in
position was theoretically supposed to
push let me know your thoughts if you
have them I know for a lot of people
this is like not even really an issue at
all uh it's just not something you think
about something that's not it's not it's
not even in sort of the discussion for
lots of folks uh something I've been
following for a while and glad to see
the decision quite frankly
we have another one of these stories of
what at this point I mean I don't know
if we just have to call this finding out
the hard way another anti-vaccine
Republican this one in particular was
pushing the big lie that Donald Trump
actually won the 2020 election but it
was stolen by Joe Biden I mean it's like
exhausting to even repeat it at this
point
um a local Michigan Republican official
Republican official reports The Daily
Beast who refused to certify Joe Biden's
presidential victory in his County
and who open very much opposed vaccines
has died of covet 19. this was 63 year
old William Hartman he we now found out
died on November 30th in a hospital in
Michigan he would regularly spread lies
and conspiracy theories about the
election on of course his Facebook page
and
um a fellow Republican on the Wayne
County Board of canvassers initially
declined to certify the tallies of the
2020 presidential election votes after
they come in and uh Hartman agreed with
that and tried also to prevent their
certification and uh ultimately they did
certify the vote counts then they said
we're going to take back our
certification some of you may remember
like we talked about this in Michigan
where there was a certification and then
they wanted to take it back but it was
too late on and on and on this same guy
William Hartman
said on Facebook that vaccine passports
resemble Nazi Germany's Draconian laws
and he has continued with this
incredible string of completely Bonkers
coveted vaccine denial and conspiracy
theories and other things and he ended
up in the hospital with the virus and he
has subsequently died we learned that he
was in the ICU
with pneumonia
and on and on and on so at this point
are these stories unique they are not
um is this at the end of the day
finding out the hard way
we knew what to do
we knew how to do it
the vaccine was free to him
and he didn't get it now with any
individual case and this is always the
important thing you will have people who
will come back and say but David can you
say for sure that if this particular
individual had been vaccinated he would
have survived and of course not nobody
is saying that what we do know is that
being vaccinated dramatically
reduces the odds that you end up very
very sick or dying and at a population
level
not necessarily William Hartman but at
the population level we know what there
is to do and part of this you know I I
hesitate to use this term but there's a
very specific way in which it makes
sense these unvaccinated Cova deaths
when these are just choices not to get
vaccinated often because of false
beliefs about the vaccine
these are wasted that these are
pointless deaths and what I mean by that
is
if you didn't do the simple thing that
would likely prevent you from dying not
guaranteed but likely you didn't do it
then it's very stupid to die in this way
in the sense that just getting a free
vaccine might have kept you alive now of
course there are people who do all of
the things that are available they they
follow various guidelines they get
vaccinated and sadly they still get sick
and die Colin Powell is one of them
that's a different situation and of
course because we know that that will
happen to some people why would we want
to add on to that by tempting Fate by
saying I'm not going to go and get
vaccinated it makes no sense in that
particular sense it's a dumb death and
it doesn't mean that getting covet is
feminine The Way Tucker said it just
means if you've not done the basics
which are free
to give yourself a better shot at
staying alive if you get this disease
then you're sort of learning the hard
way now the last thing and I've said
this before I'll say it again this is
not merely a self-resolving problem we
can look away from what I mean by that
is as we've said before if this is just
as simple as only the unvaccinated will
die
as a result of them not getting
vaccinated we could look away and say
it's sad but at the end of the day uh
it's your own funeral but it's a
contagious disease and we don't know how
many people did William Hartman infect
maybe some were too young to get
vaccinated maybe some were vaccinated
but were very sick so in getting covered
and dying how many other people might he
have taken down with him and of course
we don't know the answer but that's the
reason why we can't simply look away and
say well who cares if anyone gets
vaccinated I did and I'm I'm now
protected and it's as simple as that it
is a communicable disease and the
behavior of these people affects others
as well so tack another one onto the
list notable anti-vaxx Republican pushed
vaccine conspiracies pushed election
conspiracies now dead of covid speaking
of dying of covid
in today's voicemail we have an
interesting question about that our
voicemail number is 2192 David P you can
call any time of day really any you want
to call it 4 AM go ahead and do it
here's a caller asking you know now that
we know how sick Trump was of covid what
if Trump had died of covet
hey David uh I just had a question and
want to get your Insight on something so
as we now know Trump almost died of
covid about a month before the election
around yeah he was very sick I don't
know if he almost died but he was very
very sick early October of 2020 I want
to know what do you think would have
been the Fallout from that given the
rampancy of conspiracy theories now do
you think that there would have been
these countless uh conspiracies how the
Deep State got him just before the
election and do you think there would
have been any sort of violent protests
or riots anything like that I would love
to get your Insight thank you all of the
above all of the above I mean listen
guys if Trump had died of covid it was
it even a month three weeks before the
presidential election every conspiracy
theory you can imagine and ones you
can't imagine would have been out there
the obvious ones of course the Democrats
killed him the Deep State killed him his
political opponents killed him Dr fauci
killed you know all all of that stuff
but then there would have been more so
like the Q Anon people would have had
their own version which probably would
have been like he was about to unleash
hell upon the pedophile ring that he was
fighting and so it was actually the
pedophiles who killed him or targeted
him with covet or this was a biological
Terror assassination they they
deliberately injected him with yes covid
but also poison or anything you could
imagine
would have been proposed if Donald Trump
had not survived kovid in October of
2020 and hard to even imagine what would
have happened after that I mean I think
just Biden would have won quite frankly
I think it would have been pretty simple
but uh we don't know we will never know
because it didn't ultimately happen we
have a great bonus show for you today uh
Gavin Newsom in California is doing
something very interesting he is using
or attempting to use the exact same
framework from the Texas abortion ban to
ban assault weapons in California it's a
very wild political Switcheroo which
just might work we're going to talk
about it on the bonus show also insulin
prices a big sort of battle line when it
comes to prescription prices insulin
prices may change dramatically if
Democrats get their way we'll explain
how it relates to build back better and
I'm also going to talk about Rand Paul's
just completely pathetic hypocritical
hypocritical relief begging you may
remember many times in the past
there's a natural disaster
um
there's a proposal to get money to the
area and Rand Paul votes against it now
that a natural disaster has affected
Kentucky these tragic hurricane
tornadoes rather that hit Kentucky and
parts of Tennessee I believe over the
weekend now Rand Paul is saying if Joe
Biden doesn't get us all the money right
away for everything then he's doing a
very bad thing what happened Rand I
thought you didn't want money for these
things and they're all Hypocrites on
this Ted Cruz has been I think James
inhofe there's a whole bunch of them so
we're going to talk about that on
today's bonus show remember that
tomorrow Tuesday December 14th at 6 PM
is the final David Pacman show viewer
Town Hall of the year I look forward to
seeing you there and on today's bonus
show which you can sign up for and get
instant access to at
joinpackman.com we'll see you then
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors disco delivers
affordable science-backed skin care
treatments to your home the Disco
Starter Set helps guys fight oily skin
and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated I've had great results with it
you'll get 30 percent off at
letsdisco.com Pacman the link is down
below